e aí daí que eu quero falar é uma ideia
aqui me veio quando principalmente me
mudei com foi comentado eu passei um
tempo da minha vida um ano e meio dois
anos em são luís do maranhão como alguém
que nasceu e cresceu no litoral
paranaense foi uma experiência um tanto
quanto curiosa para mim porque quando eu
cheguei lá durante o tempo você que me
sentir um outsider um um estrangeiro em
naquele local eu trabalhava como todos
eu vivia em como qualquer outra pessoa
da cidade mesmo assim eu sempre era
visto como alguém de fora como ele não
mas você não é daqui
ah e não conta assim na época pensei aí
de repente uma coisa daqui eu não sei eu
voltei para cá e nessa volta eu notei
que as pessoas da cidade que nascida da
região que eu vivi começar na metata
diferente também eu comecei a ser
novamente tratado como alto sai daí
então eu voltei para casa e não era mais
a minha casa
eu achei isso um tanto quanto curioso e
ao começar a pesquisar mais sobre esse
assunto eu entrei em contato com este
tema com essa essa essa ideia aqui
nasceu principalmente com vários
antropólogos contemporâneos que é uma
raiva que nós como grupo social criamos
do outro essa ideia gira em torno de
dois princípios fundamentais o princípio
do que o mar o que é raiva e o que é o
outro a raiva é um sentimento mais
visceral é algumas simples humano que
todos nós sentimos ela pode tomar de
várias formas ela pode ir ser algo tão
simples quanto uma indignação porque
nosso presenciamos uma injustiça ou um
ato de que é um sinal encontramos
consideraríamos errado pode ser uma
repugnância com algo ou alguém que os
bons quando a gente vê algo que nós
consideramos sábios uso do abominável o
papel do
é como aquela simples frustração que a
gente tem quando o comprou um produto
chegou em casa e você não tá funcionando
para ter que voltar lá para o lugar
fazer reclamação ou abrir a geladeira
para o iogurte adoro tá tá estragado
é uma pequena flutuação então é algo
normal humano que você não tem que se
sentir raiva ou se sentir acomodar de
sinto raiva só não é normal nosso
já o conceito de um outro é um conceito
um consideravelmente mais complicado tem
diversos acadêmicos do meio da
antropologia da sociologia que falam
disso extensamente para quem tiver
curiosidade nutrólogos como o malinovka
ou villas-boas procurem esses caras eles
vão ver artigos em livros
especificamente falando sobre isso mas
no contexto geral uma forma mais
grosseira um outro é qualquer um que não
seja nem você nem um grupo que você faz
parte então literalmente o estrangeiro
aquele que é o o outro e um ótimo
exemplo disso aqui o outro não precisa
também inclusive ser alguém diferente
por exemplo na grécia antiga de duas
antigas cidades-estados
a quarta várias das outras cidades e
tinham cultura língua religião costumes
festivais que eram idênticas umas das
outras ou pelo menos muito parecido
assim mesmo assim ela se tratavam como o
outro ele é diferente era eu o externo
é a grande pegada do dessa raiva com o
outro que quando você mistura essas duas
ideias você já era uma ferramenta de
controle muito forte principalmente uma
ferramenta de controle social
e por quê porque você consegue quando
você faz o teu grupo sentir raiva de
outro você consegue fazer com que ele
deixa de olhar para si mesmo
e a plano dois mil anos da grécia antiga
a gente para na idade média e nós temos
uma grande quantidade de reinos
medievais que viviam em guerra entre si
metade deles estavam numa guerra outra
metade estava se recuperando para voltar
para guerra e nesse cenário aonde
claramente era visto como não nunca vai
haver paz entre por exemplo frança e
inglaterra ou os reis em específico a
igreja medieval pega toda uma etnia toda
uma religião que era vista como o outro
por esses grupos e começa a lançar
certas ideias eles não pertencem ao
lugar que eles estão eles tenham que não
deveriam ter eles são imorais porque não
seguem o que a gente acredita
e essas idéias bonfim cantando no pensar
popular das elites e vai se fortalecendo
cada vez mais isso vai virando uma raiva
começa com um pequeno as um susto
medicação tira uma raiva e com essa
brincadeira cruzadas começaram
i p
há 500 anos aproximadamente nós tivemos
constante batalhas entre reinos
medievais e os e o mundo árabe
e agora
i am
e isso acontece eu como eu falei isso é
um teu número até uma forma de controle
e um problema que muitas vezes isso não
é iniciado está raiva não é iniciada por
uma elite política por um grupo de
governantes por vezes essa raiva do
outro começa por nosso e uma elite
política daí vai usar isso para se
aproveitar da sua situação um outro o
problema maior na verdade é que essa
raiva lá cresce então pode começar a
pequena como eu falei ao iogurte só que
ela cresce ela vai aumenta logo esse ele
é diferente vira em tá errado essa
errado é ele é ilógico ele é mau seria
mal ele é menos que você porque você é
uma pessoa melhor que uma pessoa melhor
vira ele é menos que mano essa raiva do
outro tem uma série o problema que você
eventualmente você e o seu grupo
desumanizam o outro
o riso pode chegar a níveis tão absurdos
como aconteceu agora século 20 1930/40
onde seis milhões de serviços foram
executados em campos de concentração
durante o holocausto
oi e a justificativa era que eles não
eram humanos eram nem gente
oi e esse é o segredo da raiva perante o
outro é esse é o pulo do gato essa raiva
não é emocional ou pelo menos não é o
que a gente fala para nós você não mudei
o outro porque você tá com esse
sentimento visceral que eu falei do
começo você não dei o outro porque você
tem algum tipo de preconceito não tem
uma justificativa seja porque uma um
dever moral
olá seja porque era uma questão de bem
maior mas o teu ódio perante o outro tem
que ter uma justificativa isso tem que
ser vendido para nós como indivíduos que
fazemos parte do nosso grupo isso tem
que ser vendido para gente nós temos que
aceitar isso
e claro até agora também tô falando de
exemplos como 13 mil anos atrás no
início do sociedades urbanas e também
também ou agora de uma sociedade
consideravelmente autocrata mas isso é
um problema que persiste e infecta
democracias também mesmo a democracia
que um um sistema que foi até certo
ponto criado para evitar esse tipo de
coisa democracia moderna foi criada por
ele ter esse tipo de situação não pode
acontecer porque os infectam irão muito
fundo
e na década de 60 e 70 houve um medo nos
estados unidos quero fantasma do
comunismo
a trança guerra fria ninguém aqui não
sabe o que foi a guerra fria e em cima
dessa justificativa toda a sociedade
americana e muitas vezes o governo nem
era tão responsável mas eventualmente
ele entrou na brincadeira
em toda a sociedade americana começou
uma caça às bruxas a uma a um certo
outro ia ser outro é daqui em qualquer
um que tivesse uma filosofia de vida o
política mais próxima socialismo do
comunismo não encontrava aqueles eram
americanos born and raised para todos os
efeitos eles eram esse outro errado que
quer nos destruir a final porque eles
seriam socialistas e comunistas num país
que está em guerra com união soviética
diretamente que é isso que eles são
claramente queremos afetar eles estão
querendo nos acredite nós estamos que
fazer isso para nos defender
o e de novo são coisas que nos encantam
tanto que quando você radicalizar você
dá infelizmente lá no foi tão
radicalizado embora tenha sido sério se
você rádio eles o suficiente você gera
situações como a da áfrica do sul
o que até 1994 25 anos atrás
e aí ela passava pelo apartheid que para
quem não conhece foi uma um período uma
loja que eu social que eles criaram para
dividir completamente pessoas mesmo de
pessoas brancas radicalmente a crime
você conviver com alguém que não
pertence a tua raça e isso foi vendido
para a população como é justo certo
quero 16 não são científicos vocês não
sabem o que é hoje em dia hoje a gente
vê isso com um absurdo claro mas você
tem que vender isso para aquele aquele
pessoal e você se justifica com que você
tem na época
é o problema dessa de toda essa questão
é que também estamos afetando muito
pessoalmente aqui no na nossa sociedade
é uma ameaça raiva durante o outro uma
ameaça à sociedade como um todo a nossa
organização como um todo e a democracia
bom e todos nós somos afetados por ela
esse é ruim a gente nem nota mas nós
fomos afetados
é porque quem é que nunca pensou menos
de alguém porque ele acredita numa
ideologia política ou econômica
diferente ou pensou menos de alguém
porque este mesmo alguém segue um
político específico
é só que você pensar menos que alguém
não viram que eu disse virou uma pequena
raiva logo você fala ele não escuta
quanto eu ou elemento de inteligente que
eu logo ele é menos que eu logo ele não
é humano
ah e tudo isso bem fenômeno que tem nos
assombrado a diários e
é mas tem como mudar felizmente aqui
essa grande beleza que eu quero tentar
aqui vir falar para vocês dá para mudar
hoje hoje nós chegamos num nível
tecnológico que nos permite transmissão
de informação virtualmente ilimitada
instantaneamente
é porque você pode agora pesquisar sobre
o outro você consegue acabar com a raiva
dentro de você que você pesquisa sobre o
outro você entende a justificativa dele
porque como eu disse ele tem um motivo
por que puder para completamente errado
você pode abominar o motivo dele achar o
que você quiser você não tem que
concordar com ele porque dependendo
conversamos dependendo de quem você
classifica como o outro a oab ea
justificativa deles são repreensíveis
mas com certeza dentro da mente dele e
do que ele acredita há uma razão e
entender essa razão é fundamental numa
sociedade democrática porque permite que
você entenda ele como humano você
entende porque ele comete os erros os
acertos que ele comete
e nós podemos mudar todas a questão que
nós podemos entender como o outro
funciona o que ele pensa o que ele
acredita o que ele sente e quando você
faz isso você não consegue mais deus
humanizá-lo
o que você igual a ele é o seu nível ele
passa a ser uma pessoa como você é um
cidadão como você é um ser humano como
você
e novamente insisto em dizer isso não
quer dizer que você está concordando com
outro você sentar para conversar com
outro não queria que está concordando
com ele não quer dizer que você está
fazendo valer certos atos que ele comete
é mas é importante a gente fazer isso
é porque quando a democracia você pô
larissa aí você um grupo social civita
conversar com outro para quem ela então
você no final vai ser um cabo de guerra
para ver quem é mais forte
oi entendeu o outro e conversar com ele
pode gerar um crescimento tanto de nós
quanto o outro
além disso importante pro também porque
eu volto não acho que ele o outro ele
acha que ele ele você que o outro nós
vamos outro
o que é difícil não é fácil fazer isso
dependendo de quem com quem você vai
tentar conversar pode ser difícil pode
ser complicado os reais podem ser tão
conflitantes tão não impacto tão forte
um com o outro que se torna difícil
fazer mas é um esforço que nós temos que
fazer
eu vou com isso nós conseguimos nós
finalmente quebrar mas essa barreira
essa raiva este essa frustração que nos
que assola nos assola como sociedade mas
poderemos finalmente sentar e conversar
todos juntos e tentar entender algo que
vai agradar melhora todos dá para
agradar todo mundo mas pelo menos
garante que não tantas injustiças que
nós vemos acontecer todos os dias não
aconteça mais
bom dia eventualmente talvez
que a gente possa finalmente
e parar de enxergar à sociedade como nós
e os outros
e é isso aí muito obrigado tá